I want to talk about Donald Trump and
vacations Donald Trump endlessly
criticized former President Barack Obama
for the number of vacations that he took
and how much golf he played remember
this tweet Obama's motto if I don't go
on taxpayer-funded vacations and
constantly fundraise the terrorists win
another past tweet from Donald Trump
when will Obama next go on vacation if
he wins the election the day after
remember that Donald Trump said during
his campaign quote I would not be a
president who took vacations I would not
be a president that takes time off but
Donald Trump has gone on vacation four
times during his mere seven weeks as
president - none other than his Florida
Resort mar-a-lago which by the way
Secret Service and White House officials
call quote heaven for spies we already
know that Donald Trump discusses
sensitive confidential information about
global crises in the patio at mar-a-lago
in front of people taking pictures but
let's focus on the cost today these
vacations have cost taxpayers over 12
million dollars during not even two
months in office
Donald Trump has already spent one tenth
of what President Obama spent on
vacations over his eight years in office
Trump also specifically bashed Obama for
the how much golf you played situation
once tweeting in 2011 Barack Obama
played golf yesterday now he heads to a
10-day vacation in Martha's Vineyard
nice work ethic
however Donald Trump also is the pot
calling the kettle black when it comes
to golf games this past Sunday just two
days ago was Donald Trump's ninth game
of golf since taking office that is more
than a game of golf per week and it is
way more than the amount of golf played
by former President Obama Donald Trump
the guy who said he wouldn't be taking
vacations he wouldn't be leaving the
White House is on track to be the most
vacationing president in history Trump
said previously to Greta Van Susteren
about Obama quote the fact is he takes
more vacations than any human being I've
ever seen they used to complain about
George Bush but I understand he's
already exceeded George Bush and we're
not even through the year that's not
true
by the way so he likes vacation we have
a president that's constantly whether
it's Martha's Vineyard or someplace else
constantly on vacation I mean all the
time he's on vacation
so I think it sends a very very bad
message here's the facts
Trump's been on vacation during 15 days
so far that represents 30 percent of his
presidency for context President Obama
spent seven-and-a-half percent of his
time on vacation George W Bush spent 18
point 2 percent of his time on vacation
and Bill Clinton only 6 percent of his
time on vacation Bigley tremendous huh
here's the pattern with Trump if Trump
made a campaign promise that he would do
something he's not doing it as president
draining the swamp a new health care
program that would cover everybody
immediately repealing the Affordable
Care Act if he promised that he's not
doing it
if Trump made the promise during the
campaign that he would not do something
he is doing it to utter excess during
his presidency this includes vacation
this includes golfing this includes
leaving the White House this includes
appointing the same establishment
lobbyists and Republican insiders he
said wouldn't be part of his
administration the one possible silver
lining maybe is maybe more time on
vacation for Trump is time that he can't
be wrecking the country but I don't even
buy that myself because the counterpoint
is when Trump's on vacation his cronies
and Republican establishment leaders are
making decisions which arguably are even
worse than what Donald Trump would do so
yet another lie do any trumpets want to
stand up and say David I'm willing to
say that Donald Trump is a constant liar
and is breaking dozens and dozens of
campaign promises or are you just going
to pretend it's not happening